[Applause]
maybe the tiniest Crush maybe the
timeiest for us well I mean if there's a
little heat between Dante and I
there's a little heat there I heard
there's some heat between you and Dolly
Parton I love me some Dolly Parton but
nobody talking about God
like uh she loves this show so much that
you guys are talking about possibly her
coming on because she loves it so much
we are we're talking about it we're
trying to see whenever it can happen and
I'll do anything and I mean she doesn't
have to do anything but just be there
but she just she sends me a letter i you
know you'd be lucky to get one of these
pink letters in the mail it's pink it's
pink Dolly part
she's just the salt of the earth I mean
we did a movie called Joyful Noise
together and we had so much fun she
wrote all these songs and she made me
chicken and dumplings oh my God after a
day of work who the heck has time to
make chicken and dumplings dolly for me
there's nothing she can't do nothing and
she can rhyme the whole of you and I T
why she spits my Rhymes dolly is Fitz
specialized
you know because she's oh I know she's
got she's got it so she she's bringing
that the attitude but and you know she
just sent me a nice little letter to
tell girl and I can hear a voice like
girl you are badass on that show I could
just hear her and so thank you Dolly for
again for all your support but it's like
so many people like that including Dolly
who just you know thank you for taking
the time to just send me a little letter
and just a pink a pink one well the last
time I saw you was at the power of women
there I am freaking out over you I was
freaking out over YouTube I wouldn't let
you go just then oh I don't know how to
play things cool too like I'm not I've
never been cool I'm not I'll never be
cool I'm always gonna be like a Labrador
and heat like
like that's my go-to
um
and
um you are a part of a very special
campaign and that was very philanthropic
that event and I watched you give such a
beautiful speech and hung on your every
word and I would love for you to tell us
a part of the special campaign that
you're here to talk about I'm part of
this new campaign for Lenovo it's called
evolve small and what it is is being a
champion for small businesses oh yes so
we know
you know we live and breathe off of
small businesses you've started small
businesses I have I wish I had something
like this around when I had started my
small business which was a management
company my partner Shah Kim and I but
Lenovo is a Global Tech maker and they
make PCS and this year they partnered
with me to focus on minority and
women-owned business small businesses to
have you in the campaign is such a
powerful tool and so gracious of you
[Applause]
thank you
on CBS and catch Queen Latifah in her
new thriller end of the road which is
number one on Netflix right now
[Music]